Oh
parts of it and we've been a society for
the past 25 years of where finance was
king where people who put together
complex financial deals where the people
who made the highest salaries you look
the the highest incomes in the country
they tend to be have tended to be a wall
street or wall street related stuff and
and in which the business of actually
making stuff not necessarily physical
stuff but the business of actually
providing stuff that was of direct use
was definitely secondary I think that
that ear is probably over so it that's
going to change fewer Gordon Gekkos out
there in in the 21st century economy
finances I hope finance is going to
become boring again right when I was
growing up bankers were boring people
and the whole business of Finance was a
pretty boring field and and that's
probably where we're going again but as
for that I don't think it's we'll see
whether how much of a new new deal we
get in other respects but yeah basically
the whole shape of the economy zombie
challenge
you